pour les gendarmes cette piste est très
sérieuse ça colle avec la découverte sur
la scène de crime de la victime qui a le
pantalon baissé le sexe dehors il peut
être un peu une image symbolique d'un
mari jaloux qui qui le tue et le
l'humili en lui descendant son pantalon
au fil des auditions les enquêteurs
découvrent aussi car nos GIS traversait
une mauvaise passe depuis deux mois
l'homme était au chômage et il le vivait
mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ils ont pu faire un acte comme
ça c'est pas possible
[Musique]
quand on arrive sur place et nous dans
ses poignets en disant que je suis un
meurtrier
donne comme le seul responsable de la
mort d'arnaudis
ces mises à hurler quand elle a pris ça
au téléphone tout ça elle a hurlé comme
s'il y en avait enlevé l'amour de sa vie
le véritable mobile je ne sais pas si un
jour on le connaîtra
il a été laminé par son mari elle a été
manipulé par les autres elle était
abusée
le vendredi 9 juillet 2010 la journée
s'achève tranquillement à l'aigle une
petite commune de l'Orne
il est 22h30
Mélanie Flory 25 ans et son compagnon de
28 ans Arnaud GIS viennent de coucher
leurs deux enfants
Mélanie et Arnaud sont très amoureux la
jeune femme est d'ailleurs enceinte pour
la troisième fois aux alentours de 22h30
le jeune homme
Arnaud qui a 28 ans sort pour aller
boire un verre
[Musique]
dans ma forme Mélanie en disant
t'inquiète pas notamment je vais rentrer
au plus tard à 1h du matin celle-ci le
regard de partir lui fait un petit
coucou
et il part
Mélanie ne se doute pas un seul instant
que c'est la dernière fois qu'elle va
voir le père de ses enfants
[Musique]
en effet la nuit passe et Arnaud ne
revient pas
et le lendemain matin il est pas rentré
Mélanie est morte d'inquiétude cela ne
ressemble pas à Arnaud de la laisser
sans nouvelle toute une nuit alors
affoler elle appelle tous ceux qui le
connaissent en commençant par la petite
sœur de son conjoint Océane une lycéenne
de 16 ans
elle est stressée elle est stressé à
trouver je sais pas quoi dire à la peur
je m'inquiète tout de suite parce que je
me dis c'est pas son habitude de faire
ça il va être père on appelle Arnaud on
envoie des messages mais rien à faire et
répond pas donc là c'est l'ambiance
totale
à 11h du matin craignant le pire la
jeune mère de famille Mélanie se rend à
la gendarmerie de l'Aigle
le viens signaler la disparition de son
concurrent chez Arnaud parti la veille
au soir boire un verre
elle est vraiment inquiète pour lui
en plus bon aller enceinte on voit
qu'elle commence un peu à paniquer
elle dit que tout se passe relativement
bien à la maison un bon que son mari a
l'habitude de sortir de temps en temps
pour boire un verre mais il aurait
prévenu s'il rentrait pas il lui aurait
passé un coup de fil face au désarroi de
la jeune femme la situation est prise
très au sérieux car a priori ce père de
famille n'a aucune raison de disparaître
immédiatement les gendarmes se rendent
au bar ou Arnaud devait passer la soirée
quelqu'un sait peut-être quelque chose
et là ça se complique un petit peu parce
que les serveurs ne se souviennent
absolument pas d'avoir vu Arnaud guiss
la veille venir prendre une quelconque
consommation alors s'il n'était pas dans
ce bar où était le compagnon de Mélanie
les gendarmes vont donc essayer de le
localiser grâce à son téléphone portable
et il découvre que l'appareil a cessé
d'émettre à deux heures du matin
donc une commune qui est à quelques
kilomètres de la ville de l'aigle on
envoie deux patrouilles vers le
déclenchement de relais pour recouvrir
la zone parallèlement les gendarmes
sillonnent toutes les routes de la
région a fait aussi tous les voilà tous
les chemins toutes les rues de l'Aigle
sans rien trouver un téléphone coupé au
milieu de la nuit aucune trace de la
voiture d'Arnaud Gys le père de famille
c'est volatilisé
de son côté dans les locaux de la
gendarmerie Mélanie Fleury va se
rappeler d'un détail important qui
pourrait peut-être avoir un lien avec la
disparition de son compagnon en eau
semblait semblait ses stressé ces
derniers jours
et les gens n'auraient pas été content
de la vente donc il y aurait eu des
disputes une altercation à propos de
cette vente de voitures
[Musique]
et Mélanie se souvient du nom de
l'acheteur un certain Sofiane
d'après elle quelques jours après la
vente l'homme était furieux il aurait
même menacé physiquement son compagnon
et ce n'est pas tout elle va même plus
loin en disant qu'un jour les deux
hommes se sont croisés dans le
centre-ville et que l'acquéreur de la
voiture d'occasion leur est poursuivi
sur les ce dans les rues de la ville
grâce à la carte grise du véhicule les
gendarmes vont facilement
identifier cet individu
immédiatement entendu Sofiane semble ne
pas comprendre pourquoi il est là cette
histoire de poursuit ton véhicule décrit
par par un madame Fleury lui ne ni
complètement
il a reconnu avoir acheté le véhicule
arnaudis mais
très content de cet achat donc c'était
une voiture qui est usée mais qui savait
très bien à quoi s'en tenir et qui
voyait il avait aucune raison d'en
vouloir à arnologiste pour la vente les
gendarmes vont tout de même s'intéresser
à l'emploi du temps de Sofiane la veille
au soir je ne travaillais donc son NBA
était vérifié il a été mis en cause
assez rapidement
cette piste ne donne rien et pour
l'instant personne ne sait où est passé
Arnaud GIS
dans le petit pavillon familial Mélanie
est désespérée elle écrit des messages
déchirants sur Internet
sur facebook lance des appels à l'aide
un peu à tout le monde des appels à
Arnaud pour qu'il revienne elle lance un
espèce d'appel au secours
ponctué de mots traitants à l'égard
d'Arnaud guys en disant mais comment
rentrer à la maison
je ne sais pas où tu es je me suis mis à
sa place je me suis dit aller inquiète
donc oui c'est un peu normal elle est
maman et les paires de famille
un formidable et long de solidarité
secret les parents les amis les voisins
tout le monde se mobilise pour venir en
aide à la jeune mère de famille et parmi
eux il y a Stéphane le père de Mélanie
j'ai pris mon camion et je suis parti
dans tous les chercher Arnaud j'avais
l'impression qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui s'était passé je ressentais ça en
moi ça m'affolé complètement donc j'ai
traîné dans j'ai fait toutes les rues
j'étais voir des gens que je connaissais
mais peine perdus Arnaud gisney nulle
part même sa voiture reste introuvable
le dimanche 11 juillet 2010 soit 36
heures après la disparition du jeune
homme tout va basculer à 13h juste avant
que je bois l'apéritif juste avant mon
portable sonne et là c'est ma belle-sœur
qui vient de voir la voiture à Arnaud à
tel endroit
[Musique]
la voiture une Golf bleu nuit vient
d'être repéré le long d'une
départementale qui traverse une forêt à
5 km de l'Aigle
Stéphane Fleury accompagné des gendarmes
seront immédiatement sur place gendarmes
m'ont dit de ma prochaine lentement je
me suis approché lentement la partie
était légèrement ouverte et le coffre
était fermé
[Musique]
moi je vois que la voiture est vide bon
bois forêt
on va dans mon état d'esprit dit on va
aller voir dans le bois
au loin je vois un truc rouge soit un
truc rouge au loin et puis je regarde
bien mais je dis il est là-bas
au milieu des arbres à quelques mètres à
peine de la route Arnaud j s'était tendu
inerte
j'arrive dessus et là j'essaye d'enlever
le bras avec tes droits il était bien
droit et là les mouches s'envolent le
après c'est un peu compliqué quand même
voilà le gendarme viennent des
m'enlèvent dessus
et mort
[Musique]
les gendarmes boucle le périmètre et
font les premières constatations d'usage
sur le corps d'Arnaud Gys
le corps est sur le sur le dos donc il
est vêtu avec un jean et puis un démon
t-shirt rouge on retourne le corps et là
on voit sur le dos une plaie assez
importante qui était certainement faite
par une arme à feu de rocalibre une
balle de 8 mm habituellement utilisé
pour la chasse au sangliers
d'après le légiste le tueur se trouvait
tout près de sa victime et un détail
intrigue les enquêteurs
le pantalon d'enregis est légèrement
baissé
[Musique]
les gendarmes s'interrogent Arnaud Gys
a-t-il été abattu alors qu'il était en
train d'uriner pour les enquêteurs cette
hypothèse n'est possible que si Arnaud
connaissait son agresseur
croyez pas quelqu'un urinait si tu es
sous la menace du Nord ou s'il avait pas
confiance
avec les personnes avec qui se
trouvaient et d'après l'examen du corps
cette thèse est totalement plausible
aucune trace de défense qui est
découverte sur son corps très vite ça
fait penser
son agresseur mais il y a une autre
hypothèse
s'agirait-il d'une rencontre sexuelle
qui aurait mal tourné à cet instant il
est encore trop tôt pour le dire
pour trouver des indices les experts de
la gendarmerie passent la scène de crime
au peigne fin
et un ratissage qui a été fait un petit
ratissage au plus près de la zone qui
était délimitée mais rien n'a été
retrouvé
[Musique]
quant à l'arme du crime un fusil de
chasse elle est introuvable
tout comme les clés de la voiture et le
téléphone portable de la victime
[Musique]
ce dimanche 11 juillet il est environ 16
heures lorsque Mélanie apprend la
terrible nouvelle
[Musique]
hurlé comme si on avait enlevé l'amour
de sa vie
[Musique]
j'ai perdu la mort de ma vie
je me remettrai jamais quoi donc pour
elle c'était toujours encaisser la jeune
femme est totalement effondrée ses
proches redoutent même le pire
j'allais la voir dès que je pouvais mais
les enfants comme les enfants étaient
avec elle et tout j'ai dit c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible qu'elle
fasse une Correc ces enfants sachant que
ces enfants c'était tout quoi c'est sa
vie c'est ses enfants
un père de famille abattu laissant
derrière lui deux orphelins et une femme
enceinte
dans la région l'affaire est vécue comme
un véritable traumatisme
et Mélanie devient un pour tous une mère
courage bien décidée à retrouver et
faire payer le meurtrier d'Arnaud
Jérôme sage un journaliste se souvient
du courage et de la détermination de la
jeune femme Mélanie fleurit montre un
tempérament très très
revanchard ou en tout cas
vindicatif moi elle me dit si on
retrouve celui qui a fait ça il a
intérêt à courir vite
un petit trait voilà on va s'en occuper
à la gendarmerie de l'aigle l'enquête se
concentre sur la personnalité de la
victime
qui était Arnaud GIS
ses proches sont entendus et pour tous
c'est un homme en apparence sans
histoire
elle était bosseur un homme qui ne
faisait pas parler de lui et qui menait
une vie de couple harmonieuse le couple
queonde Mélanie Fleury et arnogis
remontent à peu près 5 ans auparavant
lui était bouché elle était poissonnière
a priori il peut de raison de se
rencontrer à part dans un Intermarché où
les deux rayons sont très proches l'un
de l'autre ils sont tombés amoureux ils
se sont installés ensemble et à partir
de là tout va très vite il y a un
premier enfant puis un deuxième enfant
puis le troisième qui n'est pas encore
né une histoire de couple qui va vite et
qui va bien moi je trouve ça super je
trouve ça beau bien c'est chaleureux
donc là ils sont une petite amie
tranquille
seulement derrière ce portrait idyllique
se cache une réalité beaucoup moins
glorieuse alors des auditions
apparemment il y a quelque chose qui
revient assez régulièrement c'est vers
nogis aimait bien aimé bien les femmes
quand il y a une voisine qui s'est
installée ou quand il y a une dame qui
passait dans la rue qui était lorsqu'il
était belle et dire ailleurs on est pas
mal elle est pas mal et puis regardez
comme ça et vous voyez que c'était
quelqu'un d'intéressé et ce n'est pas
tout Arnaud passait de longues heures
sur des sites de rencontres il ne s'en
cachait pas d'ailleurs à tel point que
le père de Mélanie doute de la fidélité
de son gendre pour moi il avait une
relation extra conjugale ça c'est clair
je l'ai vu à la pêche parce que je
voulais du texto à 5h30 tout le seuil
avait deux portables Il jouait du texto
du texto du texto puis s'éloigner un peu
puis il a continué puis à un moment il a
même téléphoné voilà mais je n'ai jamais
su qui c'était
et le père de Mélanie n'est pas le seul
à penser Carnot était infidèle proche de
la famille on nous parle de d'une
infirmière avec qui Arnaud aurait eu une
liaison pour les gendarmes cette piste
est très sérieuse
ça colle avec la découverte sur la scène
de crime de la victime qui a le pantalon
baissé le sexe dehors qui peut être un
peu une image symbolique d'un mari
jaloux qui qui le tue et le l'humili en
lui descendant son pantalon
au fil des auditions les enquêteurs
découvrent aussi car nos GIS traversait
une mauvaise passe depuis deux mois
l'homme était au chômage et il le vivait
mal il y avait pas d'argent
systématiquement j'avais faire des
courses avec ma femme on a amené des
commandes des produits de base des
yaourts et machin pour les enfants c'est
quelqu'un qui était assez fier
apparemment donc bon c'est quelque chose
qui le travaillait le fait de pas
pouvoir s'occuper de sa famille
correctement plus le fait que il allait
avoir un troisième enfant est-ce qu'il
allait pouvoir s'en occuper par rapport
à
plus de travail du jour au lendemain il
était pas bien dans sa peau
d'ailleurs pour oublier ses ennuis
Arnaud aurait sombré dans l'alcool je le
savais moi qui buvait et que le matin il
sentait la Vignasse quand on partait à
la pêche lui qui tremblait comme une
feuille je lui ai dit il y a un problème
d'alcool m'a dit non ça va s'arranger
des maîtresses un problème avec l'alcool
au fil des témoignages je le portrait du
bon père de famille se termine peu à peu
et ce n'est pas la seule chose que les
gendarmes découvrent Arnaud GIS avait un
casier judiciaire bien chargé il a fait
de la prison pour les faits assez grave
il a été condamné pour des vols vols
avec vol avec agression dont un vol où
il y a eu un viol donc même si c'est pas
lui le noir qui avait commis l'acte où
il était présent il était avec les avec
les individus qui avait vu et je crois
que c'était une personne âgée donc c'est
quand même des sections très graves
est-ce que son passé l'aurait rejoint
rattrapé
possible c'est également une piste
pour les gendarmes le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il y a maintenant
de nombreuses raisons qui pourraient
expliquer cette assassinat
il y a le passé assez troubles de hors
nogis qui aurait peut-être pu avoir un
lien avec son avec son meurtre il aurait
une maîtresse l'infirmière ou une autre
donc l'hypothèse d'un Marie jaloux le
pantalon baissé et le caleçon baissé on
peut imaginer un crime de nature
sexuelle pour les enquêteurs la priorité
est maintenant de reconstituer l'emploi
du temps de la victime la nuit du drame
avec qui Arnaud avait-il rendez-vous le
soir de sa mort pour le savoir il lance
un appel à témoin dans les journaux
locaux qui sait quelqu'un a peut-être vu
quelque chose
et les enquêteurs ne s'arrêtent pas là
ils font le tour de tous les lieux de
nuit de la région
autour de tout ce qui est bar brasserie
discothèque bon on a rien découvert de
conséquent les caméras de
vidéosurveillance de la ville sont aussi
visionnés en vain Arnaud n'apparaît
nulle part
[Applaudissements]
alors le 12 juillet trois jours après la
disparition du jeune père de famille les
enquêteurs perquisitionnent sont
domicile ils cherchent un élément qui
leur permettrait de savoir ce qu'a fait
Arnaud le soir de sa mort et c'est en
fouillant la cuisine qu'ils font une
découverte qui va changer le cours de
l'enquête on retrouve quand même un mot
écrit de la main d'Arnaud de ce que nous
dit Mélanie Arnaud qui s'excuse pour
avoir cassé le téléphone de Mélanie ça a
l'air de rien et pour les enquêteurs en
fait ça va ouvrir une porte ouvrir la
porte sur une éventuelle impulsivité
colère
capacité à voir rouge de d'Arnaud on
commence à comprendre effectivement que
au sein du couple c'était pas si rose
que ça
aussitôt les gendarmes demandent des
explications à Mélanie la veuve et là
contrairement à ce qu'elle a toujours
déclaré la jeune femme va alors avouer
Carnot n'était pas le mari idéal il
pouvait même se montrer possessif
à ces maladies de d'Arnaud envers son
cousin Florian
c'est son petit cousin il a été à la
maison quelques têtes et surtout dans la
famille tout le temps avec mes parents
et ainsi de suite donc c'est quelqu'un
que Mélanie connaît très bien Florian
était présent assez régulièrement au
domicile de Mélanie il y avait vraiment
une bonne entente entre eux donc il
venait souvent prendre l'apéritif il
venait souvent déjeuner avec Mélanie
cette présence quotidienne Arnaud ne la
supportait plus
[Musique]
que voudrais bien être avec Mélanie
restera un peu ensemble avec tes enfants
et tout mais que lui il en avait marre
tout ça quoi il était âge 24 au Pavillon
il faisait comme chez lui
[Musique]
d'école assez fréquentes au sein du
couple à ce sujet
face au gendarmes mais la nuit va plus
loin à demi-motel avoue être une femme
battue
qui pouvait quand il avait bu notamment
qui pouvait se montrer violent enfin en
tout cas violent à son égard et qu'il
pouvait de temps en temps la frapper la
menacer mais bon elle essaye quand même
effectivement de minimiser les choses
puisqu'elle est quand même elle vient
d'apprendre la mort de son mari Mélanie
ne va difficilement très difficilement
parler des violences conjugales qu'elle
a pu subir comme toutes les femmes
battues derrière la extrêmement de mal à
en parler personne ou presque dans son
entourage ne le sait ses parents ne le
savent pas
elle souffrait en silence de coup
qu'elle recevait de la part d'arnoïs
était quelqu'un qui était tellement
amoureuse de ses enfants puis de la
réussite essayer de réussir un couple
formidable que là vous voyez l'échec
c'est sûr et là à partir de là elle se
cacher la personnalité du père de
famille semble de plus en plus
insaisissable
[Musique]
dans un premier temps les gendarmes vont
s'attacher à la piste du règlement de
compte amoureux Arnaud GIS avait-il un
rendez-vous qui aurait mal tourné avec
l'une de ses conquêtes
l'exploitation l'ordinateur portable
d'Arnaud montre qu'il shot énormément
sur sur les sites de rencontres
qu'il a parlé plusieurs filles donc
toutes ces femmes vont être entendues et
elles sont toutes unanimes aucune
d'entre elles n'a jamais rencontré
Arnaud physiquement
idiot énormément mais en fait il ne
rencontre jamais personne
quant à l'infirmière désignait comme la
maîtresse d'Arnaud les gendarmes vont
finir par l'identifier
elle est entendue et elle dit voilà
qu'elle ne connaît absolument pas de
Arnaud GIS si on n'a pas de maîtresse il
y a pas de marine une petite amie jaloux
donc cette piste aussi se refermée
force et de constater que toutes les
pistes explorées jusqu'ici ne donnera
rien les enquêteurs se recentre alors
sur les proches d'Arnaud GIS la clé du
mystère s'y trouve peut-être
là on va se concentrer essentiellement
sur la famille à savoir donc Mélanie ses
parents et il est très proche et les
enquêteurs ne tardent pas à découvrir
que Mélanie la veuve et pleurer
entretient une bien étrange relation
avec un certain Damien Roland un jeune
homme de 19 ans
dès le jour de la découverte du corps
d'Arnaud il est présent de Monsieur de
Mélanie
au tout départ on nous dit que il est là
à la demande du père de Mélanie donc de
Stéphane qui fait confiance à ce jeune
homme c'est simple Mélanie étant toute
seule et il y aura un chien dans la
maison avec les enfants la crainte de
savoir qui avait fait du mal à Arnaud et
ainsi de suite il était là moi je lui ai
dit bah puisque tu as rien à faire
est-ce que tu veux est-ce que tu peux
rester là parce que ma fille voulait pas
revenir à la maison donc il m'a dit oui
seulement depuis ce jour-là Damien
Roland a élu domicile chez Mélanie et il
se comporte comme l'homme de la maison
et la coiffe des petits travaux des
bricoles et la travailler un petit peu
dans la maison et les enfants sont là il
aime les enfants
si cette situation ne choque pas le père
de Mélanie dans la petite ville de
l'aigle cette installation fait jaser
il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui prend sa
place moi ça me choque en fait je
comprends pas pourquoi il est là 24 dans
la maison mon frère elle a fait bâtir il
a tout le temps alors Damien Roland
était-il juste un ami dévoué où était-il
l'amant de Mélanie pour le découvrir les
enquêteurs passent les relevés
téléphoniques des deux jeunes gens au
crible le résultat était différent
s'aperçoit qu'il y a un nombre d'appels
et de SMS et des changes de SMS énorme
entre les deux fois avant et après de
mille appels sur un mois et demi il
récupère un savant de de SMS dont les
contenus sont éloquents bref ils sont
amants et maîtresse
et les gendarmes découvrent que cette
relation est bien antérieure à la mort
d'Arnaud GIS on a pu estimer qu'ils
entretenaient une relation qui a
commencé mimer l'année de l'homicile
donc de deux mois deux mois et demi
avant le avant le meurtre d'arnoulis
deux hommes pour une seule femme cette
affaire serait-elle en réalité un drame
passionnel l'histoire commence à prendre
une toute autre tournure
ça vient une femme qui prend un amant et
qui cherche à se débarrasser de son mari
en tout cas c'est une hypothèse et pour
l'heure c'est la plus probable
les deux amants sont immédiatement
convoqués à la gendarmerie les
enquêteurs veulent connaître leur emploi
du temps précis la nuit du drame
Mélanie répète qu'elle a passé la fin de
soirée chez elle avec ses enfants
de son côté Damien Roland donne un alibi
il explique qu'il a un voisin et ami un
certain je n'attends et que ce soit là
et bien comme ça leur arrive de temps en
temps ils ont passé la soirée ils nous
regardaient un programme à la télévision
puis ils ont joué à des jeux vidéo
jusqu'à une avancée de la nuit vers une
heure du matin puis ce sont séparés et
Damien est allé se coucher
Jonathan l'a mis en question confirme
ses déclarations
du coup les deux amants sont mis hors de
cause
mais pour l'instant ils ne sont pas
lavés de tout soupçon et les gendarmes
les places sous étroites surveillance
[Musique]
pendant cet été 2010 il vit vraiment
comme Marie et femme Damien s'occupe
d'ailleurs extrêmement bien des enfants
de la maison
mi-août Mélanie accouche de son
troisième enfant et forcément tout le
monde se demande si ce petit garçon est
bien le fils d'Arnaud d'autant que
Mélanie lui a donné un prénom qui
visiblement ne doit rien au hasard
dernier enfant de Mélanie porte l'un des
prénoms de Damien en fait
voulait appeler le petit dernier iron
bon en fait elle a changé de la pièce
c'est l'un des prénoms de Damien ce
dossier son deuxième prénom je crois
la question s'est posée à un moment
donné de la la réelle paternité du petit
et en définitive la question a été assez
rapidement évacuée et bien le fils
dernier
mais les deux tourtereaux ne vont pas
profiter bien longtemps de ce nouveau
bonheur
car les gendarmes vont acquérir la
preuve que Damien leur a menti
en effet on vérifiant la position GPS de
son portable il se rendent compte que le
soir du meurtre l'amant n'était pas
comme il l'a déclaré avec son ami
Jonathan
donc a été classé en garde à vue et bon
tout de suite il a dit que il avait
menti lors de son audition qui n'avait
pas vu Damien Roland le soir même
si Damien Roland qui lui avait demandé
de mentir qui lui avait dit qu'il avait
fait une une connerie avec les flics une
course-poursuite je crois une mémoire
qu'il avait mentionné et que ça serait
bien qu'il le couvre
et le téléphone portable de la main va
livrer une autre information capitale
c'est qu'il déclenche le relais qui se
trouve à proximité de l'endroit où était
découvert le corps d'enregistre la nuit
du meurtre Damien Roland était donc dans
le périmètre de la scène de crime dès
lors il devient le suspect numéro 1 dans
la mort d'Arnaud GIS
[Musique]
mais une question reste en suspens quel
est le rôle exact de Mélanie pour le
savoir les enquêteurs décident
d'interpeller les deux amants le 21
septembre au petit matin c'est très
étrange genre leur réaction parce que
ils sont pas spécialement surpris voilà
Damien surtout Damien il est calme il
est très coopératif
Damien et Mélanie sont placés en garde à
vue à la gendarmerie de l'aigle ils sont
entendus séparément
Damien Rolland qui n'a que 19 ans est
très impressionné alors que
l'interrogatoire débute à peine le jeune
homme s'effondre je fais sa rencontre à
ce moment-là
il est temps là il est complètement
abattu Damien Rolland lui dès les
premières questions va littéralement
comme on dit s'affaler se mettre à table
ses premiers mots de dans son audition
sont j'étais à Rungis
un aveu terrible et l'amant de Mélanie
explique son geste d'après lui Arnaud
GIS était un tyran chez lui il accepté
pas son le comportement d'Arnaud donc
elle regarde de Mélanie puisqu'à priori
ils sont très violents avec elle Arnaud
GIS lui a toujours été présenté comme un
homme violent
agressif plus que tout encore c'est du
mal aux enfants
selon ses déclarations Damien voulait
donc protéger sa maîtresse
et il va donner le récit précis de cette
nuit d'été où il a donné la mort à
Arnaud GIS
il va faire aujourd'hui
de cette soirée en réalité c'est lui qui
a tendu un traquenat à son copain parce
que Arnaud guys à l'origine et son
copain
pour attirer le père de famille dans les
bois Damien va lui proposer un
cambriolage
se trouve carnotis est au chômage depuis
quelques mois que il attend un enfant
qui n'a pas de rentrer d'argent du coup
il accepte assez rapidement un
rendez-vous qui est fixé avec Arnaud GIS
dans le bois
avec l'intention d'aller cambrioler une
maison forestière
quelques heures avant le drame Damien a
pris soin de cacher un fusil de chasse
sur le lieu du rendez-vous
[Musique]
le piège n'a plus qu'à se refermer le
soir même il se retrouve avec Arnaud GIS
et arnaudis donc dans sa voiture la Golf
pas le véhicule et jusqu'à cet endroit
[Musique]
ils arrivent dans un chemin et l'argus a
besoin d'aller faire pipi voici
précisément ce que Damien déclare
aujourd'hui
il s'est décalé vers la gauche vers la
forêt pendant ce temps-là j'ai été
chercher l'arme
et après j'ai fait trois ou quatre pas
et je me suis dirigé vers lui il était
de dos et moi derrière
[Musique]
j'ai hésité mais j'ai tiré
Damien Roland complète ses aveux en
expliquant avoir pris le téléphone
portable et les clés de voiture d'Arnaud
puis il a pris la fuite il se donne
comme le seul responsable de la mort
d'Arnaud GIS
dans le même temps dans une salle
voisine
Mélanie est elle aussi entendue par les
enquêteurs voyons qu'elle essayait j'ai
pas de charmer mais en tout cas de nous
apprivoiser quoi la jeune femme est
catégorique contrairement à son amant
elle déclare qu'elle n'est pour rien
dans la mort d'Arnaud lorsqu'on fait
part Mélanie des aveux de Damien
Le elle nous dit c'est pas possible il
dit n'importe quoi
Mélanie elle conteste
en disant que
elle n'était pas au courant que la prend
là et que il comprend vraiment pas
pourquoi ça c'est ça s'est passé
c'est une histoire de fou il a même pas
d'armes à feu qu'est-ce qu'il raconte il
dit n'importe quoi
la seule chose que la jeune femme admet
c'est sa relation amoureuse avec Damien
Roland
il va reconnaître que bah oui
effectivement avec Damien Roland c'est
un peu plus que de l'amitié
Mélanie explique que pour elle Damien
n'est qu'une passade elle sait qu'il
l'aime mais elle s'est sentiments sont
amicaux et encore
vous dites que vous n'êtes pas amoureuse
de Damien en êtes-vous sûr
c'est pas le grand amour
il vous disait je te quitte je pars de
la maison comment réagiriez-vous qu'il
parte je ne le retiens pas
depuis le début de son interrogatoire
Damien et catégorie Mélanie n'a rien
fait mais les enquêteurs ne sont pas du
même avis ils décident alors de
déstabiliser le jeune homme on lui
répétant mot pour mot ce que sa
maîtresse a dit de leur relation
et pour Damien c'est la douche froide il
pleure il
crie se sentant trahi Damien lâche
totalement sa maîtresse
d'après lui Mélanie était parfaitement
au courant du projet criminel
est-ce que Mélanie savait comment vous
alliez commettre un meurtre oui donc
elle a laissé partir Arnaud en sachant
qu'elle ne le reverrai plus ouais
et Damien Roland va même plus loin c'est
Mélanie l'instigatrice de cette
assassinat
il explique que effectivement elle était
au courant
et en définitive il finit par dire ce
qu'il en est c'est à sa demande ça
demande répéter depuis des semaines et
des semaines et des semaines que il a
fini par le faire pour elle par amour
pour elle et pour la protéger elle et
les enfants
pour preuve Damien raconte que juste
après avoir abattu Arnaud il a envoyé un
texto à Mélanie pour l'avertir que le
travail avait été fait
[Musique]
ce qu'il y a un code entre eux qui a été
convenu
donc au code c'était bonne nuit donc il
lui envoie ce code juste après avoir
tué un logis
et le jeune homme d'enfoncer le clou
lorsqu'il rejoint Mélanie chez elle
après le crime celle-ci se montre très
soulagé
[Musique]
se montre même heureuse et alors que lui
n'aspire qu'à une chose
c'est d'aller s'effondrer sur un lit
elle se montre même excitée et
va lui demander et faire le nécessaire
pour que
il disait une relation sexuelle voilà
Mélanie elle continue de clamer son
innocence elle n'a rien fait et rien
demandé à Damien d'ailleurs c'est lui
qui a pris seul l'initiative de tuer
Arnaud GIS
effectivement elle a pu lâcher deux
trois fois que elle en avait assez que
des coups et de la violence et de
l'alcool mais sans sans aller plus loin
j'ai dit fallait que ça s'arrête oui ça
s'arrête mais qu'il arrête de me donner
des claques qu'il arrête de medurier
elle n'a jamais demandé à Damien de tuer
Arnaud ça même ni même de l'agresser de
ça les former
il voyait bien que c'était pas tout rose
à la maison mais jamais je ne lui ai dit
tu vas m'aider ou autre
alors
dit la vérité Mélanie Fleury ou Damien
Roland
pour les gendarmes difficiles de faire
la part des choses
et c'est à ce moment-là qu'un nouvel
acteur va intervenir dans cette affaire
il s'agit de Florian souvenez-vous le
cousin de Mélanie qui lui aussi était au
courant d'une meurtre
Damien nous nous dit effectivement que
dès le lendemain lendemain matin il a
rencontré Florian et lui a avoué qu'il
avait sûrement
[Musique]
Florian est immédiatement placé en garde
à vue et le jeune homme ne tarde pas à
se mettre à table il charge sa cousine
sur en disant l'instigatrice de tout
c'est elle qui a poussé Damien comme
être summertre l'une n'hésite pas à dire
qu'elle a joué avec lui et que très
clairement un lieu de turno
je suis sûr que c'est ma cousine qui la
manipulé Damien c'est son petit chien
Damien était le larbin de Mélanie
Florian va même plus loin selon lui il y
aurait-tu deux autres tentatives
d'assassinat auquel Arnaud GIS aurait
échappé toutes les deux fomantées par
Mélanie
la première remonte au début du mois de
juin soit 5 semaines avant le drame
ce jour-là Damien l'amant et Florian le
cousin son chez Mélanie ils attendent
deux pieds ferme le retour d'Arnaud
prélèvement Damien était allé à la
demande de Mélanie en pharmacie pour
acheter pour acheter les somnifères et
ils attendent tous les trois l'arrivée
d'Arnaud Guy
or ce soir-là Arnaud guise ne veut pas
arriver tout seul il va arriver avec un
copain qui s'appelle Benoît Mélanie il
est là tant pis pour lui on ne change
rien notre plan on y va
Mélanie aurait mélangé des somnifères
aux apéritifs de Benoît et Arnaud
les deux hommes vont s'effondrer
quelques minutes plus tard
totalement drogué
là Damien et Florian vont les porter
dans un lit et l'idée c'était de les
étouffer avec un coussin puis ensuite de
maquiller ça en accident de la
circulation
seulement ce jour-là rien ne va se
passer comme prévu
surtout dans le lit
je peux pas
pour autant le trio ne désarme pas
[Applaudissements]
toujours selon Florian 10 jours plus
tard le cousin la femme et l'amant
aurait fait une nouvelle tentative cette
fois-ci ils auraient prévu d'abattre
Arnaud chez lui avec un fusil
c'est Damien qui est au manette enfin je
veux dire qu'il y a l'arme à la main
donc il se présente il sonne armée d'un
fusil de chasse en pleine nuit et une
nouvelle fois Damien renonce
les saisies par la peur et s'enfuient
seconde tentative avorter ce soir-là
également
[Musique]
durant toute sa garde à vue Florian le
cousin détaille minutieusement les
complots successifs à l'encontre
d'arnaudis un récit que Damien l'amant
va confirmer
Florian et Damien sont entendus
séparément ils disent la même chose donc
a priori de fortes chances que ce soit
vrai quant à Mélanie le conteste
farouchement
[Musique]
elle est décrite par deux comme étant le
marionnettiste qui agit vraiment et qui
reste au dessus de la mêlée et qui leur
dit vous allez faire ci faire ça qui
organise tous les plans et qui pense à
tout
à l'issue des gardes à vue Damien
Rolland est mis en examen pour
assassiner
Mélanie fleurie et mise en examen pour
complicité d'assassinat
ils sont tous les deux immédiatement
écroués
Florian lui qui n'a participé qu'aux
tentative et mis en examen pour non
empêchement de crime il est placé sous
contrôle judiciaire
lorsque la famille d'Arnaud découvre les
foyables complots le choc était terrible
c'est insupportable comment ils ont pu
faire un truc un acte comme ça c'est pas
possible mais la neige la connaissais
très bien pourquoi elle a fait ça quoi
je me dis ça n'aimait plus Arnaud
pourquoi pas de l'avoir crité ou ou
voilà mais pas tuer quelqu'un sachant
que voilà il a donné la vie à des
enfants et en plus surtout que tu
méritais pas ça quoi
[Musique]
pour la juge d'instruction une question
cruciale demeure pourquoi Mélanie Fleury
a-t-elle voulu faire disparaître son
compagnon
[Musique]
les violences conjugales dont elle a
fait part à Damien son amant mais aussi
aux gendarmes
ont-elles réellement existé
difficile de le savoir un tour non dit
qu'elle avait été violentée par son mari
à plusieurs reprises simplement on n'a
jamais on n'a jamais eu vendre tout ça
c'est elle n'a jamais déposé plainte
aucun membre de sa famille n'est venu se
manifester dans ce sens là jamais on
nous a dit ma fille ou ma cousine ma
nièce est victime de violence et si la
jeune femme avait tout inventé pour y
voir plus clair la juge d'instruction
ordonne une expertise psychiatrique
c'est le docteur lorto qui rencontre
Mélanie Fleury c'est pas quelqu'un qui
qui s'invente des histoires mais qui
croient au moins un temps elle est
absolument pas délirante non plus
quand elle travestit la vérité cette
façon consciente oui
[Musique]
Mélanie Flory aurait menti mais a-t-elle
pour autant demandé à Damien d'exécuter
Arnaud ou Damien a-t-il agi seul
une chose est sûre en lui disant qu'elle
était une femme battue mélanie a joué
sur la corde sensible de son jeune homme
il était dans la position de défendre
une femme malheureuse ça correspond tout
à fait à ce qu'il n'a pu nous dire de la
relation à sa propre mère
instable avec laquelle il avait connu
plusieurs beau-père des hommes
éventuellement violents il n'avait pas
été capable de défendre sa mère fallait
qu'il sauve madame Fleury si je dis les
choses comme ça
le 26 novembre 2012 le procès s'ouvre
devant la cour d'assises de l'Orne
Mélanie Fleury et Damien Roland encore
tous les deux la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
la salle d'audience est comble tout le
monde veut voir ce que l'on surnomme
désormais les amants diaboliques
je m'attendais à tomber sur une femme
fatale d'un côté et puis un tueur froid
et déterminé de l'autre même s'il avait
été amoureux et en réalité j'ai vu un
gamin quant à elle elle a rien d'une
femme fatale c'était très surprenant le
décalage de de l'histoire et des
personnages qui ont animé cette histoire
le jour du procès c'est la première fois
depuis deux ans que Mélanie se retrouve
face à la famille du père de ses enfants
celle que tu es mon frère donc je me
suis dit je capte même pas
dans le box les deux accusés font profil
bas on avait Damien Rolland qui avait la
tête baissée et qui regardait ses
chaussures pendant les trois quarts de
du procès on voit que il est pas bien du
tout il pleure il est pas bien
quand Mélanie Fleury elle est arrivée un
peu décoiffée avec ces espèces de
lunettes
tasser dans son box pleurnichambre dans
un temps mais n'acceptant jamais
d'affronter la réalité la vérité en face
tout au long des débats Mélanie Fleury
continue de clamer son innocence mais
dans la salle elle ne convain personne
pire elle s'enfonce les avocats m'ont
dit c'est une catastrophe elle réagit
mal elle réagit pas elle elle mélange
tout
chaque fois qu'on lui posait une
question à lui autant je crois à la
sincérité de Damien Roland je pense que
ce type était amoureux
fou amoureux autant elle apparaît un peu
comme un serpent glacial froid
on a vraiment le sentiment qu'elle s'est
servi de cet homme pour se débarrasser
du mari gênant l'avocat général requiert
30 ans de prison à l'encontre des deux
âmes
après trois heures de délibéré les jurés
rendent leur verdict ils ont unis dans
leur crime
ils ont condamné à 20 années de
réclusion criminelles tous les deux
Florian le cousin de Mélanie et pour sa
part condamné à 3 ans de prison pour non
dénonciation de crime
[Musique]
aucun des trois accusés ne fait appel du
jugement
[Musique]
pour la famille d'Arnaud le verdict
n'atténue pas la rancœur
[Musique]
en oubliant tout ce qui s'est passé
quant au père de Mélanie Fleury
impossible pour lui d'accepter la
culpabilité de sa fille était laminée
par son mari elle a été manipulée par
les autres elle était abusée et
maintenant les coupables
il y a aucun élément concret qui prouve
que ma fille a demandé de tuer Arnaud
donc tant qu'on me le prouve pas je ne
le crois pas
[Musique]